[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
quel avenir pour l'eau en France
32 à 35 milliards de mètres cubes par an
ces grandes quantités d'eau prélevez
chaque année dans les nappes ou les
cours d'eau sont nécessaires pour
produire de l'énergie et fabriquer les
produits que nous consommons au
quotidien avec le réchauffement
climatique le cycle de l'eau va se
modifier prévienne Catherine belriti
Cécile cucquermann Alain Richard et
Jean-Sol dans un rapport fait au nom de
la délégation à la prospective pour
éclairer un large débat qu'ils appellent
de leurs vœux les rapporteurs ont traité
8 questions sur l'avenir de l'eau à
l'horizon 2050 les
usages la gouvernance et la gestion de
l'eau sont passés au crible
les rapporteurs constatent avant tout
une baisse généralisée des débits des
cours d'eau l'allongement du temps de
recharge des nappes et l'accroissement
de la sécheresse des sols ainsi que de
leur érosion face au stress hydrique et
à la multiplication des épisodes de
sécheresse les rapporteurs préconisent
deux stratégies complémentaires la
sobriété qui consiste à économiser l'eau
et la mobilisation de la ressource
lorsque le service environnemental est
économique rendu est positif il est
urgent d'accélérer l'adaptation des
pratiques agricoles aux nouvelles
tensions hydriques en parallèle la
délégation soutient la création de
retenue d'eau qui se remplissent l'hiver
à partir de la collecte d'eau de pluie
pour être utilisé l'été
la recharge artificielle des nappes
phréatiques est également envisagée la
délégation à la prospective souhaite par
ailleurs encourager la recherche et
l'innovation par exemple dans la
réutilisation des eaux usées
afin de maîtriser les coûts de la
gestion de l'eau les rapporteurs
appellent également à augmenter les
moyens financiers des agences de l'eau
dans l'objectif de permettre aux
Français de continuer à disposer d'une
ocène et de bonne qualité le rapport
conseille d'encadrer l'usage de
substances polluantes et d'interdire les
plus préoccupantes d'entre elles en
matière de gouvernance de la gestion de
l'eau la légitimité des choix passe par
une repolitisation de ces instances et
par le renforcement de l'échelon local
de prise de décision estime les
rapporteurs
dans cette optique il plaide pour une
accélération et une généralisation de la
mise en place des projets de territoire
pour la gestion de l'eau le rapport
suggère enfin de mettre en place une
pédagogie de l'eau auprès du grand
public
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]